ce ne sont pas les oiseaux qui ont volé
les premiers les ptérosaures avait
conquis le ciel 60 millions d'années
avant l'apparition du premier oiseau
puis il disparu laissant fort peu
d'indications sur la façon dont ils
vivaient les ptérosaures connaît aussi
sous le nom de ptérodactyle n'était
autre que des reptiles volants cousins
des dinosaures 65 millions d'années
après la disparition du dernier
ptérosaures les scientifiques se
demandent encore comment des reptiles
ont pu se mettre à voler
au bord de la mer ni au bras il y à 85
millions d'années
un jeune t'es rauser déploie ses ailes
il va effectuer son premier vol
son envergure de près de sept mètres lui
permet de planer au dessus des eaux bleu
afin d'y traquer sa première proie
des carcasses d'animaux ont coulé
jusqu'au fond des eaux tranquilles de la
mer ni au bras elle s'y sont fossilisés
sans que rien ne soit jamais venu les
déranger
un lit crayeux et poussiéreux et tout ce
qu'il reste aujourd'hui de 7 mais il
s'étend du dakota du nord jusque au
nouveau mexique
c'est l'un des rares endroits en
amérique où l'on peut trouver des
fossiles de ptérodactyle tout comme les
dinosaures les ptérodactyles étaient des
reptiles il ressemblait bien davantage à
des lézards cas des oiseaux est
cependant comme les oiseaux les
ptérodactyles pouvait voler
parmi les derniers de ces reptiles
volants on trouve le tehran au dos le
paléontologue chris bennett a passé des
milliers d'heures à la recherche de
fossiles de ptérosaure prisonniers du
calcaire dans le lit de la mer ni au
bras il y à 85 millions d'années cet
endroit se trouvaient au fond de la mer
à environ 200 mètres de profondeur il
s'étendait de l'océan arctique jusqu'au
golfe du mexique
la côte la plus proche était à environ
200 kilomètres d'ici cette mère était
très certainement peuplé de grands mots
adore les arts gigantesques aux moeurs
marine
on y trouvait aussi des kélonia ou
tortues de mer et des plésiosaures sans
parler de toutes sortes de poissons le
terrain l'aude ont survolé ce monde sous
marin à la recherche de nourriture
prenant chaque jour son essor grâce aux
courants aériens ils pouvaient planer
sur de longues distances
il battait occasionnellement des ailes
pour gagner de l'altitude
comme le font encore beaucoup d'oiseaux
de mer il scrutait les vagues à la
recherche de bancs de poissons est passé
certainement la plus grande partie de
son temps à se nourrir
le soir ils se reposaient sans doute à
la surface de l'eau comme les albatros
que nous connaissons
au cours des cent vingt-cinq années
écoulées on a déterré ici même on se
sent fossiles de tirano dont à l'automne
2008 170 un éminent paléontologue de
l'université de yale oc marche à
explorer cette région les membres de son
équipe parme et de fusiller le couteau
de chasse semblait partir à la conquête
de l'ouest
à l'aube de la paléontologie les photos
constitué de beaux souvenirs a envoyé à
la famille et aux amis restés sagement à
la maison tout comme d'ailleurs les
fossiles de tirano dont la découverte
par marche du terrano dont ouvrir un
nouveau chapitre dans l'histoire des
ptérosaures les ptérosaures n'étaient
pas des dinosaures
les paléontologues pense qu'ils
descendent de petit reptile à quatre
pattes qui vivait il ya 250 millions
d'années 25 millions d'années plus tard
les ptérosaures avait appris à voler
certains pensent qu'ils sont le résultat
de deux mutations successives
on l'a baptisé les premiers renforts
accuse les fossiles découverts nous
révèle qu'il ne dépassait pas la taille
d'un pigeon le renfort un cus possédait
une tête maigre et allongé avec un bec
bien pourvu de dents il s'en servait
probablement pour transpercer le poisson
repérer et le sortir de l'eau
ces premiers ptérosaures possédait une
queue longue et osseuses qui leur
servait de stabilisateur un peu comme
sur un cerf-volant leur évolution
définitive est caractérisée par un super
petit doigt en effet le quatrième doigt
de chaque patte est devenu plus long que
leur corps tout entier
il servait de support à une aile les
autres doigts d'une taille normale
portaient des griffes les premiers
renforts accuse son vieux de plus de 200
millions d'années 50 millions d'années
plus tard il s'était diversifié en de
nombreuses variétés sur toute la surface
du globe
les fossiles retrouvés jusqu'à présent
permettent de dire que les renforts un
cul sont apparus il ya 230 millions
d'années et ont vécu pendant environ 50
millions d'années pour des raisons
inconnues
ils ont disparu il y à 180 millions
d'années une deuxième sorte de
ptérosaure les ptérodactyles sont venus
prendre leur place
il se diversifiait rangs plusieurs
groupes étrange les premiers pouvaient
se comparer à une grive mais après
quelques millions d'années
certains à tenir la taille d'un bimoteur
avec une envergure de 35 m leur poids
varié de quelques grammes à 100 kg la
plupart perdirent leurs dents mais elle
fut remplacé chez certains par des poils
très dur qui devait leur servir à
filtrer l'eau pour retenir leur
nourriture
cette nouvelle forme de ptérodactyle
conserver une tête couronnée d'une crête
magnifique qui pouvait atteindre 2 fois
la longueur de leur corps les os de la
tête était devenu très léger et les
coups longs et flexible s'apparentait à
ceux des oiseaux leur queue dont
l'utilité en vol avait disparu se
réduisit considérablement
c'est précisément la perte de leurs
longues queues qui marque un changement
important chez les reptiles volants sans
celle ci ils dépendaient beaucoup plus
de mouvements des ailes pour pallier les
changements de vent cela sous-entend une
intelligence plus développée que celle
des premiers renforts à cus
dans l'évolution des espèces pouvoir
voler est sans doute le phénomène qui a
demandé les efforts les plus ardus les
scientifiques définissent de stade dans
le vol prendre son essor et battre des
ailes pour prendre son essor
l'animal utilisent les courants aériens
et la dépense d'énergie minimes comme
chez les chauves souris et les oiseaux
le squelette des ptérosaures supporter
de puissants muscles qui contrôlent l
heure l immense le paléontologue bob
barker pensent que leur développement
musculaire indique que les ptérodactyles
possédait une grande résistance en vol
si on analyse les membres antérieurs et
postérieurs d'un terreau d'actifs ainsi
que son sternum
on constate qu aucun autre animal n'a
jamais développé une telle aptitude et
une telle puissance pour voler
pratiquement chaque gramme de chaque
muscle est dédié aux vols battre des
ailes demande une grande force
musculaire et beaucoup d'énergie
cela nécessite aussi un métabolisme
compliqué et par dessus tout un
métabolisme à sang chaud
il faut également faire preuve d'une
plus grande intelligence
certains scientifiques pensent que
c'était le cas des ptérosaures leur
aptitude à voler était servie par un
squelette robuste et léger
kevin pas dionne paléontologue à
l'université de berkeley a
particulièrement étudié l'anatomie des
ptérosaures et la façon dont ils
volaient ce qu'on doit savoir sur les os
du pied rose or c'est que ce sont les
plus fins qu'on puisse trouver chez un
invertébré celui ci est plat comme une
crêpe on dirait qu'il est passé sous un
rouleau compresseur
cette hausse provient d'un membre
antérieur sa paroisse est tellement
mince qu'on dirait un derder ce que
j'appelle un derder
c'est ce tube de cartons qu'on trouve au
milieu des rouleaux de servette en
papier ça fédère derder canton le
déroule
et bien si on aplatissait ce tube en
carton
il ressemblerait à cette hausse des
parois très mince et rien au milieu rien
sauf de l'air
on pourrait alors logiquement penser que
c'est assez fragile mais il n'en est
rien nous avons vérifié cette hypothèse
avec l'aide d'ingénieurs de stanford
lors de notre travail en commun ils nous
ont démontré que c'est son grand
diamètre qui rendait ce membre
particulièrement résistant creux au
centre les eaux du ppte et rose or avait
des parois d'une épaisseur suffisante
pour résister à l'épreuve physique du
vol
des études ont même démontré qu'ils
étaient à 80 6% plus robuste que des
hausses similaires chez les mammifères
les scientifiques sont d'accord sur un
point
même les plus grands ptérosaures pouvait
voler mais comment
il y à 200 millions d'années une grande
mer recouvrait cette région du sud de
l'allemagne
des animaux vivent au bord sont parfois
tombés dans l'eau leurs cadavres se sont
ensuite retrouvés ensevelis dans des les
pots vases et au fur et à mesure que
passaient des millions d'années ces
dépôts se sont transformés en calcaire
et pendant des siècles ce calcaire a
fourni des tuiles et des pierres de
taille
mais vers la fin du xviiie siècle
quelque chose de surprenant fut extrait
de cette carrière
un fossile étrangers tordus qui avait
une tête et un corps de lézards ses
longs doigts retourné était tout à fait
bizarre
ils ressemblaient à ceux d'un dragon
comme pratiquement tous les fossiles
intéressant découvert en ce temps là
celui-ci atterri sur le bureau du
brillant zoologiste français georges
cuvier et après l'avoir examinée il
écrivit si ce fossile reprenait vie il
ne ressemblerait à aucun animal connu
pour cette époque qu'ils ignoraient tout
de l'extinction des espèces la
déclaration de cuvier était tout
simplement révolutionnaire
commença alors à germer une idée qui
servit de base aux théories
transformiste cuvier baptisa cette
étrange créature terreau d'actes il ou
elle doit il était évident pour lui que
l'os tellement allongée du dernier doit
avait soutenu une espèce d'elle d'autres
chercheurs essaient hier d'expliquer
comment des reptiles primitif aurait pu
acquérir le pouvoir de voler ils se
mirent d'accord pour annoncer qu'ils
veulent est mais à peine parce que dans
le cas contraire il existerait encore le
paléontologue anglais david unwin de
l'université de bristol s'est penché
avec passion sur l'évolution des
ptérosaures pendant de très nombreuses
années on a été persuadé qu'il volait
fort mal on le croyait tout au plus
capable de se jeter du haut des falaises
et d'atterrir lourdement sur le sol puis
de recommencer sans fin la même
opération
au début du siècle un géologue anglais
s'il est a écrit un livre très populaire
intitulée dragon dans les airs ayant
passé une grande partie de son temps à
étudier les ptérodactyles ils étaient
persuadés qu'ils étaient parfaitement
adapté au vol et avait le sang chaud son
opinion personnelle ne suscita aucun
écho et les ptérodactyles perdit
rapidement l'intérêt qu'ils avaient
suscité de grands savants décidèrent que
les insectes de mise à part la première
tentative de vol et s'étaient soldées
par un échec
en 1870 le professeur sylla de cambridge
a publié une magnifique monographie
consacrée aux articulations des
ptérodactyles il y est expliqué en
détail comment elle fonctionnait il
était certain qu'il s'agissait de
créatures à sang chaud comme les oiseaux
qui volent est parfaitement mais à
partir de 1930
il ya eu un retournement d'opinion on a
recommencé à dire que les ptérodactyles
avait de mauvaises articulations que
leurs ailes étaient faibles qu'ils
arrivaient tout juste à prendre leur
essor et que la moindre turbulence dans
l'air les déstabiliser complètement le
vol des ptérosaures dans l'obscurantisme
allait encore durer une cinquantaine
d'années jusqu'à ce qu'une nouvelle
génération de scientifiques dépasse la
vision hollywoodienne et décide de les
étudier d'un oeil neuf et les
ptérosaures passèrent sans transition du
rôle de rater de l'évolution à celui de
pionnier du vol ont fait ville persuadé
que pour la première fois sur terre un
animal autre qu'un insecte avait
développé une aptitude à voler les
prédécesseurs de ces reptiles et les
apparaissent à peu près à la même époque
que les premiers dinosaures
il y à 225 millions d'années c'est paul
sereno qui a trouvé certains des plus
anciens fossiles jamais découvert il a
ainsi fait remonter encore plus loin
dans le temps l'arbre généalogique des
dinosaures est sans doute également
celui des ptérosaures nous pensons donc
les ptérosaures ne sont pas issus d'une
mutation des dinosaures il résulte de
l'évolution d'une espèce différente de
reptiles et cela pratiquement à la même
époque
c'est à dire que si l'on remonte l'arbre
généalogique des dinosaures aussi loin
que possible
on n'y trouve aucune trace des
ptérosaures
aucun chercheur ne sert pas comparer un
ptérosaure les seuls autres vertébrés
qui peuvent voler sont les oiseaux et
les chauves souris depuis le 19e siècle
certains paléontologues crois que les
ailes des ptérosaures ressemble à celle
des chauves souris
c'est à dire qu'elles ont l'aspect du
cuir et s'étendent le long du corps
entre les membres antérieurs et les
membres postérieurs
cl attachés à leurs pattes postérieures
leur offre une grande résistance en vol
mais les embarrasse singulièrement quand
elles ont atterri
elle marche alors gauchement à quatre
pattes en soulevant leur zèle encombrant
du dessus du sol des vidals wind fait
partie de ceux qui croient que les ailes
des ptérosaures étaient similaires
oui les elle semble avoir été assez
analogue à celle des chauves souris et
il s'agissait de membranes de pau qui
s'étendaient le long du corps jusqu'au
pas de postérieur le bord antérieure de
l'ale été fixé au bras et en particulier
au quatrième doigt très allongée
trois autres petits doit se terminer par
des griffes grâce à son poids léger à
ses grandes ailes le ptérosaure a dû
être un excellent planner sur la terre
ferme il devenait probablement une
créature gauche est presque des armées
une fois leur grande aile repliée le
long du dos ils devaient se servir de
leurs membres postérieurs pour se
propulser en avant sur le ventre tout en
prenant appui sur les 3 doit déployer de
leurs membres antérieurs
d'autres scientifiques croient que les
ptérosaures n'avait que deux pattes et
des ailes étroite attaché aux hanches
comme les oiseaux et que comme il
marchait sans aucun problème
c'est ce que pense le paléontologue
kevin papillonne les ptérosaures marché
comme les oiseaux et comme les
dinosaures
ce qui nous fait dire ça c'est que leur
pelvis et leurs membres postérieurs sont
disposés comme ceux des dinosaures et
des oiseaux si on observe la cuisse on
constate que la tête du fémur
s'emboîtent parfaitement dans la cavité
tout à fait comme le nôtre alors
examinons notre fémur qui possèdent
cette importante articulations à rotule
si nous le voulions nous pourrions
envoyer nos jambes par là où marcher
comme ça mais nous ne le faisons pas
regardons le reste de la jambe
les ptérosaures et des oiseaux ont ce
même fémur avec l'articulation des
genoux et un très long tibia ils ont
aussi une cheville qui fonctionne comme
une charnière dans cette direction alors
ils devaient marcher comme ça à la façon
des oiseaux il prenait appui sur leurs
doigts légèrement tournée vers
l'intérieur comme ceux des oiseaux et
des dinosaures il plaçait ensuite tout
naturellement une patte de vent
les fossiles ont donc donné lieu à
différentes interprétations mais on n'a
trouvé aucune trace assez évidente pour
déterminer si les ptérosaures ressembler
davantage à des oiseaux ou à des chauves
souris
le paléontologue chris bennett estime
lui que ces comparaisons ne sont pas
suffisantes
je pense effectivement qu'on peut
apprendre des tas de choses sur les
ptérosaures en les comparant aux animaux
volants d'aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire les
oiseaux et les chauves souris mais je
demeure persuadé que les ptérosaures
étaient aussi différent des oiseaux
qu'ils l'étaient les chauves souris tout
ce qu'on peut dire avec certitude c'est
que les ptérosaures ressembler à des
ptérosaures notre image du petit rosacée
modifié au fur et à mesure de nouvelles
découvertes de fossiles mais la place
qu'il occupe dans notre imaginaire n'a
jamais perdu son importance boubakeur a
suivi les traces des ptérosaures selon
des méthodes scientifiques mais
également à travers la culture populaire
j'aime et je sais que beaucoup de gens
les aiment aussi la façon de voir et
scientifique a fait un tour complet
pour éprouver de grandes émotions à la
vue de ptérodactyle il suffit de
regarder un bon film qui ne coûte par
exemple la scène où un énorme perron
dactyle noir est très laid sans tarder
fairway elle hurle et king kong l'assaut
mais on a commencé à réaliser
aujourd'hui que les plis road actes il
n'était ni noir ni laid il ne s'agissait
pas de monstre à la vague allures de
chauves souris
la question de la structure d elle n'est
donc pas tranché et les scientifiques
continuent à chercher des indices qui
pourraient les éclairer il est possible
qu'ils trouvent la réponse dans le lit
crayeux de l'ancien maire ni au bras
on y des terres encore des fossiles qui
permettent de mettre en place une partie
du puzzle constitué par la vie des
ptérosaures il ya plusieurs dizaines
d'années que les paléontologues
admettent qu'il y avait deux sortes de
petits rats notons les fossiles de nos
bras montre clairement que certains
étaient très grand avec une envergure
pouvant dépasser 7 mètres et une énorme
crête couronnais leur tête
d'autres les plus nombreux étaient
beaucoup plus petit est muni d'une crête
modeste s'agissait-il de deux espèces
différentes
chris bennett croit avoir résolu le
problème
les grands ptéranodon possédait
d'énormes crête qui pouvait dépasser la
longueur de leur corps les plus petits
avaient des crêtes modeste mais un
bassin plus large
le fait que la différence entre les deux
se résume à la crête à la taille et au
bassin m'a conduit à penser que les plus
grands étaient des mâles et les plus
petits des femelles
bennett a déduit de l'analyse des eaux
que la croissance des jeunes terrano
dont étaient très rapides ne dépassant
pas quelques centimètres dans l'oeuf
il avait déjà une envergure de 7 mètres
au moment de quitter le nid cela
signifie qu'il bénéficiait d'une
attention constante des parents qui
devaient les nourrir régulièrement et
copieusement de poisson la grande taille
atteinte aussi rapidement par le pdt
terrano dont passionné les cherchait
quand une nouvelle trouvaille vin lui
faire de l'ombre
on découvrit au texas
en 1972 un ptérosaure qui mit toute la
communauté scientifique en émoi on
baptisa ce géant d'une envergure de 15
mètres et demi
qwise alcoa plus d'après le nom de la
divinité précolombiennes du mexique ce
qui signifie serpents oiseaux étudie à
partir d'un seul os énorme de son aile
quoi d'alcoa plus fut l'un des derniers
reptiles volants est certainement le
plus grand il vivait il y environ 70
millions d'années dans la période du
crétacé à la fin de l'époque des
dinosaures
pendant le crétacé la région actuelle de
big band au texas était une plaines
d'inondation ou se déverser plusieurs
rivières
le paysage était surtout constituée
d'étendues de sable parsemées de rares
forêts le quad alcoa plus se
nourrissaient très certainement de
mollusques et de crabes qu il broyait à
l'aide de son bec sans dents
il n'est pas exclu qu'à l'image du
vautour il se souhaite également nourri
de cadavres d'animaux noyé en plein vol
avec son envergure dépassant 15 mètres
et un poids pouvant atteindre 100 kg le
queens alcoa +2 vais ressembler à un
avion militaire
la découverte de cet animal volant
gigantesque repose à une question restée
longtemps en suspens est ce que
l'évolution réjouit un sale tour aux
ptérosaures en les rendant trop lourd
pour qu'il puisse continuer à voler en
1985 paul mc 3 des ingénieurs
aéronautiques s'associer à des
scientifiques pour tenter l'impossible
ils décidèrent de construire une
reproduction du plus grand père other
jamais découvert
cette version moderne du queen's alcoa
plus donnerait une image précise du plus
volumineuse animal ayant jamais réussi à
voler il ne restait plus qu'à espérer
qu'ils veuillent bien décollé mercredi
lens a sans difficulté ses premiers
prototypes qui étaient conçus comme des
planeurs
mais le succès ne fut pas au rendez vous
il observait alors la nature qui lui
offrit la solution évidente
il fallait que cet ersatz de ptérosaure
puisse battre des ailes pour remplacer
les muscles il mis au point des moteurs
miniaturisés qui permettait à son robot
non seulement de battre des ailes mais
aussi de les orienter
ainsi que sa tête et ses pattes pour
compenser les changements du vent mais
est ce que la technologie pouvait
vraiment reproduire ce que la nature
avait si patiemment sculptés au cours
des siècles
à la fin 2009 185 queen's alcoa plus fit
ses grands débuts dans la vallée de la
mort en californie
et pour la première fois depuis 65
millions d'années l'ombre d'un petit
rosoor balaya la terre
en fait la reproduction élaboré par mc
crédit ne faisait qu'un quart du poids
du queen's alcoa plus et ne mesurait que
la moitié de sa taille elle parvenait
cependant à donner une idée très claire
de la puissance de vol de cet animal
préhistorique
les ptérosaures ont vécu plus de 150
millions d'années à la même époque que
les dinosaures
et comme les dinosaures ils ont disparu
il y à 65 millions d'années
certains chercheurs ont suggéré que les
ptérosaures ont trouvé trop difficile de
s'adapter au vent violent qui firent
leur apparition avec les climats plus
froids du tertiaire dès la fin du
crétacé tous les reptiles volants
s'éteignaient les oiseaux prirent leur
place dans le ciel à l'époque où les
ptérodactyles disparurent complètement
ils étaient tous devenus énormes
il avait dépassé la limite supérieure
après laquelle on est menacé
d'extinction
les oiseaux et comptait des espèces
variées de taille petite ou moyenne
il sonde ont survécu parce qu'il s'était
en dessous du seuil fatidique les
ptérodactyles qu'ils étaient tous au
dessus se sont éteints
les ptérosaures ne vivent plus que dans
l'imaginaire des paléontologues
mais ce que nous continuons à apprendre
sur c'est goliath de la préhistoire
jette quelques lumières sur un monde
encore indistinct un monde que nous ne
pouvons visualiser qu'en laissant
s'envoler notre imagination